As our first step into
studying intersections,
we'll consider the most basic situation,
two lines in two dimensions.
While basic,
we will start to see structures and
procedures that will remain
present in more complex examples.
A line in two dimensions can be
defined by two essential properties.
A point it passes through which
I'll call the base point and
a vector that gives
the direction of the line.
Given the base point x naught and
the direction vector v, we can represent
all points on the line in the form x
of t equals x naught plus times v.
Notice that I'm abusing notation by
treating points as vectors here.
This means given any number t, we can
find a point on the line by plugging in
t to the expression x naught
plus t times v and computing it.
If we were to theoretically plug
in all possible values of t and
plot them, we'd end up with a plot
of all the points on the line.
This expression is called
a parameterization of the line.
Since we are expressing
the line via the perimeter t.
For example, for the line x of t
equals the vector one negative two
plus t times the vector three, one.
Taking t equal to zero gives
us the output one negative two
which is the base point for
this parameterization of the line.
If we take t equals one
then we get the output four negative
one another point on the line.
If we take t equals negative one-half
then we get negative one-half negative
five-halves, yet
another point on the line.
Note that a given line has
infinitely many base points,
since we can pick any point on
the line to be the base point.
And it has infinitely
many direction vectors,
since we can multiply any direction
vector by a positive scalar and
it will still point in
the same direction.
We could also multiply the direction
vector by a negative number and
the same set of points
will be in parameterized
just starting from
the opposite direction.
We can multiply the direction
vector by zero though, or
else we'll collapse the line to a point.
You may have seen lines written
in the form y = mx +b where b and
m are numbers.
This equation and
codes both a base point and a direction.
b is the y intercept,
the y coordinate of the point at
which the line intersects the y axis.
This gives the base point 0,b.
m is the slope of the line which can be
translated into a direction vector of
the form 1 m.
For every unit of movement
in the x direction
there are m units of
movement in the y direction.
This equation for representing
a line isn't perfect however,
since we do not have the ability
to define vertical lines.
A more general form of equation for
representing a line is Ax+By = k.
Where A, B and k are numbers and
at least one of A or B is non-zero.
To reconstruct a base point from
this equation, there are two cases.
Assuming B is not zero,
you can set x to be any number.
I'll take it to be 0 for
this example, which becomes the x
coordinate of the base point.
Then you can solve for y to find
the y coordinate of the base point.
Having taken x equals zero,
this becomes y equals k over B.
So a base point for
the line is 0, k over B.
On the other hand if B does equal 0,
then A will not be 0.
Let y = 0 in this case solving for
x gives us x = k/A.
So a base point will be k/A, 0.
So for this example here two possible
base points would be 0, 2 and 3, 0.
Now let's think about
the direction vector.
If we write down any
two points on the line,
then the vector connecting the point
will be a direction vector for the line.
In this example, we've already written
down two points on the line but for
a general case,
how would we find the direction vector?
Let's start with a very particular case,
when the constant term k = 0.
Here the equation reduces to just
Ax+By = 0 and notice that this
line passes through the origin since
the base point for this formula is 00.
If we draw the vector from the origin
to another point x, y on the line
then the corresponding vector xy will
be a direction vector for the line.
Now here's a neat algebraic trick,
rewrite
the left hand side of this equation
as a dot product of two vectors.
Ax+By becomes the vector AB
dotted with the vector XY.
Now what does this equation mean?
It means that the point
x,y is on this line.
If and only if the vector xy,
a direction vector for
the line is orthogonal to the vector AB.
This means we can find
a direction vector for
this line by picking some
vector orthogonal to AB.
One good way to do that,
in two dimensions at least,
is to just swap the coordinates
in the vectors in the gate one.
So picking B,-A, would give us
a direction vector for this line.
So for the case of this pink line,
a direction vector would be 3,-2.
Now what if k doesn't equal zero?
What changing k does is it shifts
the line off of the origin.
It doesn't actually change
the direction of the line at all.
So a direction vector for
Ax+By = k regardless of
what k is will still be B,-A.
So, both the pink and
green lines will have three
negative two as direction vectors.
One reason this way of looking at
the equation Ax+By = k is important, is
that it gives us an implicit description
of the line as a single equation.
In particular as the set of points
such that, a particular vector
dotted with those coordinates x and
y equals a given number k.
this form also let's us quickly
read off the coordinates for
a vector that is orthogonal to the line
also called a normal vector to the line.
In this case a normal vector for
the line 2x+3y = 6 will be 2 3.
Since any vector that is parallel
to this line will be
orthogonal to the vector 2 3.
We will explore this concept
further when we look at
planes in three dimensions as well as
when we start using linear algebra to
solve systems of equations.